and at the end of every sprint, they organize a demo session
to share the output of what they've done, transparently.
And every day,
each member of the team gives an update
of what they are working on individually.
Now, all this transparency can be uncomfortable for people,
because suddenly, there is no place to hide anymore.
Everything we do is transparent for everyone.
So, alignment is not easy,
and providing autonomy is not so obvious, either.
One executive at another company
likes to explain how he used to be a master of milestone-tracking.
Now, today, to know how things are going,
instead of looking at status reports,
he needs to walk down to the team floors to attend one of their sessions.
And instead of telling people what to do,
he looks for ways to help them.
That is radical change
for someone who used to be a master of milestone-tracking.
But in the old world, this executive said,
"I only had the illusion of control.
In reality, many projects would run over time and over budget, anyway.
Now I have much more transparency,
and I can course-correct much earlier if needed."
And middle managers need to change as well.
First of all, without the handovers and the PowerPoint,
there's less of a need for middle managers.
And in the old world, there was this idea of thinkers and doers.
Employees would just follow orders.
But now, instead of only managing other people,
middle managers were expected to become player-coaches.
So imagine, for the last 10 years,
you have just been telling other people what to do,
but now you're expected to do things yourself again.
Clearly, this model is not for everyone,
and some great people leave the company.
But the result is a new culture
with less hierarchy.
And all of this is hard work.
But it's worth it.
The companies that I worked with,
they were used to deploying new product features a few times per year.
Now they have releases every few weeks,
and without the handovers and the red tape,
the whole organization becomes more efficient.
And finally, if you walk the halls of these companies today,
you just feel a new energy.
It feels as if you're walking the halls of a very large start-up.
Now, to be fair, these companies, they cannot claim victory yet.
But at least with this new model,
they are much better prepared to respond to change.
The world is getting faster and more complex,
so we need to reboot our way of working.
And the hardest part of that change is not in structure
or process or procedure,
and it's also not just senior executives taking charge.
Leaders will be all of those in the organization
who embrace the change.
We all have to lead the change.
So the question is:
What are you willing to give up?
Thank you.
(Applause)